[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANO MARKS: Hi, I'm
Mano Marks.
Welcome to another
edition of Google
Maps Developer Shortcuts.
Today, I'm going to talk to you
about the Google Maps SDK
for iOS and using it with
storyboards, so this will be a
really quick short shortcut.
Storyboards, as you probably
know, are a powerful tool for
rapidly developing your
user interface for iOS
applications.
Storyboards are in the latest
versions of Xcode, so we're
just going to take a
quick look at it.
There's a lot of people out
there think that you can't use
storyboards with the Maps SDK,
and those people are wrong.
So just a quick look here--
don't have time to do a full,
like, these are storyboards,
but just taking a quick look at
the storyboards here, you
see we have a table view
controller, prototypes cell,
which I have used to create my
segue, and the segue controls
what data gets sent
to the next view.
And I simply dragged
from control--
control dragged from the
prototype cell in the table
view into my view controller
over here which is where I
create my map.
So this view controller, which
is just a standard view
controller that I dropped in
here, and then I popped in my
class, MR Map View Controller,
to load the map.
And in MR Map View Controller,
I created an object MV.
You can actually see it's a GMS
Marker Options object that
gets synthesized
when it loads.
And here we have, in view did
load, when that gets passed
in, that MV gets passed in, Add
Marker With Options MV.
And it just grabs the position
from the map view options, the
latitude and longitude,
and then sets the
camera to that location.
Now how did I get here though?
If we go back to the MR View
Controller, which is the
controller for the table view,
I created a table with just
one cell, and that's Sydney,
a a table data array.
Then I created another NS array
of GS marker options,
added one in there.
And in the prepare for segue
method, I have if the segue
identifier is equal to show
map view, which it is, it
finds the index of the table
view, the index path for
selected row.
And then it finds that row.
And then from the coordinate
data array, which is the GMS
marker array, it passes that
corresponding object over to
the map view.
And let's just take a look
at what that looks like.
So this is my table with my
simple one location, Sydney,
and you can see it shifts
the map view over to
the map view there.
And the nice thing about this
is it just handles quite
naturally on its own, the
flow back and forth
between these two pages.
Now, if I take a look just at
the View Controller, just to
prove to you that it did, when
I originally load the map, I
create a camera position
with latitude and
longitude, zero, zero.
So you can see that when it
passes over the GMS Marker
Options object, it then uses
that to find the current
location, and create
a marker there.
So that's it.
That's our shortcut for today.
Hopefully, you are all out
there creating iOS
applications, and if you use
storyboards, it's a very
powerful tool to
get you going.
So thanks for joining us,
and see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]